To get acquainted with R,
let's do some basic
calculations.
We can add numbers, multiply
numbers, and we can invoke
built-in functions to do more
complex calculations.
So R is good at calculations,
but we don't want to type in
all of our data.
Instead, we'll often store
our data into R objects.
In a later video, we'll load
in larger data objects, but
for now let's create some
simple R objects.
Let's save the value 4 to
an object called x.
Usually we use a less than
symbol followed by a dash to
communicate that we want to save
something like a number
into an R object.
Now we can use x to do some
basic calculations.
For example, x times x, or
we can calculate the
square root of x.
Note that sometimes people might
call x a variable, so
think of the terms "object" and
"variable" as meaning the
same thing in R. The names of R
objects can include letters,
numbers, underscores,
and periods.
However, the name should always
start with a letter,
usually one that is lowercase.
If you'll be sharing your code
with others, check with your
group to see if there's a style
guide that you should
follow for your R code.
One last tip--
if you want to review an earlier
command you made,
click the command line on the R
console and then hit the up
arrow on your keyboard.
When you do this, you will be
able to see earlier commands
you have run, and if you desire,
you can re-run them.
In the next video, we'll create
and work with the
vectors in R.